mental health physical conditions and
other personal struggles have caused
some of our favorite hollywood stars to
leave the industry it's always
heartbreaking to see them go but
sometimes they're happier for it keep
watching to find out why these actors
quit hollywood
many 90s kids will remember amanda bynes
turn in nickelodeon's all that her zany
attention stealing energy was watchable
enough to land her a sketch show of her
own fittingly called the amanda show and
a lead role on what i like about you
from there she transitioned to film
picking up lead roles in what a girl
wants in 2003 and the teen shakespeare
flick she's the man in 2006.
she also appeared as part of the
ensemble cast of hairspray in 2007 which
made a tiny profit at the box office in
2010 she played the gossipy moralizing
mean girl in eza opposite emma stone
another well-received teen literary
adaptation despite these apparent
successes vines tweeted in 2010 if i
don't love something anymore i stop
doing it i don't love acting anymore so
i've stopped doing it just a month later
vines tweeted that she had quote
unretired she then deleted her twitter
account altogether only to get a new one
these were the early signs of what
became a long and highly publicized
series of mental health episodes
including a string of duis hidden runs
and an arrest she also accused her
father of abuse only to recant this
claim in a bizarre tweet she wrote my
dad never did any of those things the
microchip in my brain made me say those
things
but he's the one that ordered them to
microchip me she threatened a lot of
people with a lot of lawsuits reserving
particular fire for any tabloid that
claimed she was misusing drugs
finally in 2013 vines entered rehab in
2014 she tweeted that she had been
diagnosed with bipolar disorder and
manic depression and that she was in
treatment these days she seems to be on
the mend although easy a remains her
last role she revealed in a 2017
interview that she was three years sober
and wanted to act again
a hot commodity in the 1990s and 2000s
cameron diaz had a very successful
career earning enough money to lead
several lifetimes of luxury from her
first acting experience in 1994's the
mask to her starring turn in there's
something about mary and from spike
jones's being john malkovich to martin
scorsese's gangs of new york her
filmography shows considerable range yet
creative block happens to the best of us
this is why diaz hasn't appeared in a
film since the 2014 musical comedy
remake of annie speaking at a summit
hosted by gwyneth paltrow diaz said i
just went i can't really say who i am to
myself which is a hard thing to face up
to i felt the need to make myself whole
she has few regrets about retiring and
has kept busy over the last seven years
in 2015 diaz married good charlotte lead
guitarist benji madden and four years
later their daughter radix was born
i love him so much it hurts
before that in 2016 diaz published her
book the longevity book the science of
aging the biology of strength and the
privilege of time it was followed by
2013's the body book feed move
understand and love your amazing body
christopher reeve had a thriving career
a graduate of juilliard he had his
breakout role in the original superman
movie from 1978 and continued to work on
several other projects including the
remains of the day in 1993 and many
plays
in 1995 reeve attended a dressage and
show jumping event in culpeper virginia
he learned to ride in 1985 for his
performance as count vronsky in anna
karinina and fell in love with the sport
developing a close bond with eastern
express his american thoroughbred
tragically eastern express suddenly
bulked on the third jump in the final
competition sending reeve over the
saddle and onto his head crushing his
first and second vertebrae this
devastating injury paralyzed the actor
from the neck down causing him to use a
wheelchair and ventilator for the rest
of his life
according to one of reeve's physicians
the actor would have died instantly had
he fallen one centimeter to the left and
experienced only a concussion had he
fallen one centimeter to the right
reeve was not a quitter though he pulled
through intense grief and suicidal
thoughts to lead a busy life reeve
campaigned for research into spinal
injuries and stem cell therapy raising
some 138 million dollars for researchers
around the world he forayed into
directing and had a few appearances in
shows like the tv remake of rear window
and the cw's smallville but his acting
experience largely ended with the
accident after a period of ill health he
died of heart failure in 2004 at age 52.
in 1985 michael j fox became one of
hollywood's hottest young actors with
the role of marty mcfly in back to the
future a rip-roaring sci-fi comedy that
topped the box office and became a
classic of american cinema fox reprised
mcfly in two sequels while continuing
his run on the hit nbc sitcom family
ties he also starred in teen wolf bright
lights big city and casualties of war
it was during the production of doc
hollywood in 1991 that fox noticed his
finger was twitching and that he had a
creeping pain in his shoulder
these were symptoms of early onset
parkinson's disease a shocking
revelation since most people who get the
condition are over 60. doctors told the
29 year old star that he would have to
quit acting in just a few years but he
proved them wrong with a busy career
that included roles in mars attacks and
stuart little his biggest success was
the emmy-winning sitcom spin city which
saw him play deputy mayor of new york
city mike flattery for 103 episodes i i
completely forgot we
would just bring it
fox retired from the show in 2000
because of his worsening condition
regular tv work followed in the 2000s
and 2010s including turns in curb your
enthusiasm the good wife and the michael
j fox show a sitcom inspired by the
actor's life sadly he wrote in his 2020
memoir that he was entering a second
retirement because of new symptoms
including delusions memory loss and
dementia shelly duvall was once one of
hollywood's most recognizable faces she
rose to fame in the 1970s for her
collaborations with celebrated director
robert altman including brewster macleod
mccabe and mrs miller nashville and
three women nearly all of these are now
considered must-watch classics her
success continued into the 80s with such
films as stanley kubrick's the shining
in 1980 robert altman's popeye from the
same year and roxanne in 1987
after tv appearances and supporting
roles in the 1990s duvall quit hollywood
in 2002 leading a reclusive life with
her husband in her home state of texas
in 2016 she gave an interview on dr phil
that raised serious questions about her
mental health disheveled and barely
recognizable deval made a series of
bizarre claims like insisting robin
williams was still alive and that he'd
become a shape-shifter saying he looks
real good in some forms in other forms
he doesn't do you see him has yes many
commentators derided the interview
calling it quote craven and sensational
in january 2021 seth abramovic of the
hollywood reporter managed to locate
duvall in texas hill country and
interview her happily abramovich found
that duvall possessed a sharp memory
full of engrossing stories in the
nuanced reflective piece he noted while
she can be gripped by anxiety attacks or
meander into unsettling descriptions of
alien surveillance programs she can also
converse for long coherent stretches and
conjure up the slightest details about
her life abramovic speculated that duval
fled to texas for both mental health and
financial reasons although it's sad that
we won't see her considerable talents on
screen it is reassuring to know that the
dr phil interview was a tabloid
misrepresentation of her mental health
mara wilson became one of the biggest
child stars in hollywood after her
performances in mrs doubtfire and
matilda however when wilson reached
puberty in the early 2000s the role
suddenly dried up when she did get
auditions she realized she was getting
typecast as a quote fat girl stock
character speaking with people magazine
wilson said i realized i don't fit their
idea of what a hollywood actress looks
like so there's no room for me here she
also said sometimes i wished to be in an
accident where i'd injure my nose and
jaw so i could get reconstruction
guilt-free wilson decided to focus on
schooling rather than her acting career
eventually attending new york university
sadly the pressures of hollywood stayed
with her especially when she saw
actresses her age like scarlett
johansson and kristen stewart on
magazine covers
fortunately wilson was able to manage
these anxieties through writing these
days she lives in new york as a comedy
writer voice actress and a notable
twitter persona
tim curry has had a long and busy career
logging some 236 credits on imdb this
eclectic body of work includes the rocky
horror picture show it the hunt for red
october clue and congo as well as dozens
of tv appearances and broadway shows the
british actor was working on around six
projects a year when he suffered a
debilitating stroke in 2012 which
affected his speech and caused him to
use a wheelchair since then curry has
only done voice acting he has credited
his sense of humor as being quote
absolutely vital to his recovery he also
said it's not tough to maintain it is
just part of my dna oh
you're just in time for your party he
made one of his first public appearances
since his stroke to accept a lifetime
achievement award at the 19th actor's
fund tony awards viewing party in 2015.
he was very grateful for the award
explaining it solidifies the kind of
work the american acting community has
given me for years now i was thrilled
when they told me and i am thrilled now
sometimes the critics really do hurt
this was the case for greta garbo whose
1941 film two-faced woman was so
maligned that the iconic actress left
tinseltown she was 36 years old and had
made 31 movies in just 20 years which
reflected not just her work ethic but
also her enormous popularity in both the
us and her native europe she had even
made the transition from silent films to
talkies a rare feat among her
contemporaries yet garbo found little
satisfaction in her career referring the
solitude she pursued from 1941 until her
death in 1990 at the age of 85 she was
almost persuaded to return on two
occasions first an offer to play french
novelist george sand and then a lead
role in alfred hitchcock's the paradigm
case ultimately she decided to stick to
her private drifting lifestyle she wrote
in a letter to her friend martha
vautmeister i am almost always alone and
talk to myself i drive to the beach and
take walks and that's always marvelous
but that's it i want to be alone
francis farmer had dreams of a theater
career when she signed a seven-year
contract with paramount in the mid-1930s
under this contract she performed with
bing crosby in rhythm on the range cary
grant in the toast of new york and
walter brennan in come and get it still
craving success on the stage farmer
joined big broadway productions she was
splitting her time between new york and
los angeles when her mental health
collapsed in 1942
a year that brought her divorce drunken
traffic violations and the cancellation
of her contract
farmer spent the rest of the 1940s in
and out of hospitals and sanitariums she
claimed she was abused at these
institutions in her posthumous
autobiography though there's some
speculation that the book may have been
embellished after a comeback appearance
on this is your life in 1958 farmer had
several television parts and a role in
one film the party crashers this would
be one of her last on-screen
performances farmer died of esophageal
cancer in 1970 at age 56 partly because
of her radical leaning politics in her
youth and partly because of her tragic
life
farmer became something of a cult figure
even kurt cobain was a fan if you or
someone you know is struggling with
mental health please contact the crisis
text line by texting home to
741-741 call the national alliance on
mental illness helpline at
1-800-950-n-a-m-i-6264
or visit the national institute of
mental health website